well thursday night's heavy rain flooded
areas of town but one community tells us
this has happened more than once and it
should not have happened the first time
candace charles joins us live near
fremont and bruce in downtown las vegas
candace the flooding isn't just blamed
on the rain is it
that's right kristen folks here tell me
is not just about the heavy rain good
evening folks take a look at the drain
here residents here tell me that there
was a mesh over this drain yesterday and
the fire department had to take it off
because of that heavy rain flooding the
area that water had nowhere to go and
unfortunately went into the front yards
causing flooding destruction and a big
mess
this is the fence of my next-door
neighbor
there was three feet of water
behind that wall
and it all burst through that was about
two weeks ago when heavy rain fell and
fled at laura joliet's neighborhood she
tells me she thought the worst was over
but thursday night it happened again it
was all the way coming up again
i was mortified joliet's neighborhood
sits near the corner of charleston and
spencer where construction to prevent
this type of issue has been underway for
months at a recent meeting with las
vegas city council the company las vegas
paving told residents that mesh was put
on the drains to prevent dust from
flowing through the tunnels during
construction they told us that the
coverings the mesh coverings that they
put on the screens
did not contribute
to the flooding of this
neighborhood we all highly disagreed
with that statement with no reprieve
damage from the two floods have come
with a high price from what i've heard
from the neighbors it's been pretty
close to about 20 thousand or more in
damage residents tried to get funding
from fema for the damage but didn't
qualify because it wasn't enough
disaster apparently now these neighbors
hope the city acts before another storm
causes more damage to me it just seems
really sad that you know this is
somewhat of a lower income area built a
lot longer ago and just seems to be a
bit forgotten about
now i did speak with city officials on
the phone about 30 minutes ago they did
tell me that they emphasized with
empathize excuse me with the residents
here in the community but that it has
not been officially
made that this mesh was the reason
behind the flooding of course they're
still looking into it and they do say
that the construction project is a big
one that they're expecting it to be
finished by next year or 2024. of course
we'll be looking into all of that so
stick with us right here on air online
and on social for the latest for now i'm
candice charles 8 news now